box with a break in between then we'll
have to have a longer break for lunch
um i think we are already being recorded
right
yes we're good wonderful thank you okay
that's in the case uh clara please go
ahead stage is yours
okay thank you very much thank you all
of you for attending live
and as was mentioned earlier please feel
free to ask questions
uh it's a pleasure to remember this
great semester
we had in berkeley unfortunately we
can't meet face to face but still it's
nice and i'm also
having coffee in the appropriate mug
just in uh thinking about berkeley
so i'm going to tell you about the
lighting network
about its costs about the implication of
it of the costs
it is a joint work with google hubermann
from columbia university and paolo
gustini
from dublin university so
before we oh good
before we jump into the details i want
to have a quick second for a meta
discussion
so we all know and love bitcoin but we
know also
that is both slow and expensive and the
lightning network
is a secondary solution built on top and
supposed to solve
all this problems and make bitcoin more
usable more approachable and so on
and the lighting network is being built
right now
so decisions crucial decisions about the
system
are happening pretty much as we speak
and decisions that will be made
now it's going to be very difficult to
change them in two or in three years
this is why i think it's very very
important to study lighting network
right now and so to help make the
correct decisions
taking this whole network into
a direction that we see as good positive
and so on so um
let's go ahead and jump right in okay so
i'm going to talk
about the lighting network then i'm
going to talk about the cost of a single
channel
then the implication of this costs on
the network
and finally as much as time allow we
will
do a short discussion and i'll present a
few open
problems that i find interesting so
first of all uh channels in the
lightning network so the basic of the
basics i assume a lot of you know them i
know this but just to um make sure
that we know where we're standing this
was introduced by
a pun and raja in 2016 and in general
in a lightning channel there are two
parties each party commits a sum it
doesn't have to be the
same and once the sums are committed
into the channel
they can pay each other by changing the
balances
so as an example let's assume that alice
and bob
open the lightning channel and they
commit four and six bitcoin respectively
okay so we have
alice with four bitcoin bob with six
now for example alice wants to pay bob
one bitcoin
the only thing they need to do is to
change the balance to three and seven
so the important thing is that the
opening of the channel is done
on chain which means we need to wait for
the for the transaction to be approved
and we need to pay
the transaction fee but once we got this
started
alice can pay bob and bob can pay alice
as much as the channel allows
but there's no other limits and all of
this happens
in communication between them so they
don't need to inform anybody they don't
need to pay fees
everything is happening only between
them and
once for example alice gives bob one
bitcoin over the channel
bob is guaranteed to have it so we have
that
and so there's no limit to the number of
updates
alice and bob can do and that's it's
done by exchanging sent messages it's a
pretty cool system we're not going to go
into that but i strongly encourage you
to look into it because it's very
interesting
and the important part is that at any
point alice can decide to close the
channels
to close the channel and take the
balance
that she she is supposed to get so
in our picture at any point alice can
decide to close the channel
take the three bitcoin and then bob will
get
the seven bitcoin if bob cooperates this
happens quickly
if bob doesn't cooperate alice will have
to wait but still
in the end she'll get her money if
yeah so if bob doesn't cooperate it's
just a matter of time until this happen
and a if alice is trying to cheat bob
for example by claiming she never paid
him and she still has the four bitcoin
bob can punish alice
by just taking all of the 10 bitcoin to
himself
okay so all in all generally speaking
everybody can sleep well at night and
know that
no shenanigans can happen from the other
side
so these are the channels there are the
basic building blocks
but things become more interesting when
we talk about
links so if there is a channel between
alice and bob
and the channel between bob and charlie
alice doesn't need to open
a new channel to pay charlie she can use
uh the ch she can use bob if he allows
it
to transfer uh money from her to charlie
again bob needs to allow this the way
it's
done in general let's assume these are
the channels
we have in the beginning then alice
wants to
pay charlie a single bitcoin so she will
transfer
a single bitcoin to bob and bob will
transfer
a single bitcoin to charlie okay so we
see
that alice paid charlie one bitcoin
and bob started with 10 bitcoins and
still has
10 bitcoins um and in general the chain
can be much longer
there's no at least theoretical limit
buildings four
five a whatsoever um any questions up
until here
if it's new to anybody
okay so it seems we're doing good and
yeah
so in general these channels and the
links between them
gives raise to what we call the
lightning network
okay so we have the basics done and then
and now we can go to the main questions
that were
that we were interested in when we were
thinking about the economics
of the lighting network so a basic
question
is when should the channel be opened
what's going to be the cost of the
channel if we have decided that indeed
we want to open one
what are the implications of the network
on the network
of these costs and what issues could the
economic incentives bring
to the lightning network in general so
we're going to go
to some extent into each one of these
questions
good so um i'll
quickly go over previous works so
actually
um things that we're relying on at least
in the main ideas go back to the 50s and
60s
to very classical papers by baumel tobin
and miller orr
they of course had no idea what's a
lightning network or bitcoin or anything
like that
but still the questions they asked and
answered there
are relevant to
to the study of the lightning network
that network is more complex but we can
still
draw a lot of inspiration from there
more recently
their works on portfolio choices
and in 2017 we started seeing
papers studying already the lightning
network as it emerged
and started to interest people people
are studying the economics the game
theory they're doing simulations they're
studying this
the current state of the network and
there are many more
results and there's it's a growing field
with interesting papers coming quite
often
so let's talk specifically about our
model
and for this we first of all need to
introduce
the model for channels so our
assumptions are going to be the
following
and now we're going to in a channel
there's going to be
two nodes node one and node two we're
assuming that node one
wants to send a single bitcoin to node
two
with poisson arrival time with some rate
lambda one
similarly the second node wants to send
the bitcoin to node one
again with the personal arrival time
with the rate
lambda2 okay and we're assuming that
these two processes
are independent okay so each node
decides
at the wrong time and when do they want
to start
so we're assuming for now that node one
is going to commit
l1 bitcoin to the channel and o2 is
committing
l2 bitcoin okay and this is the starting
position
where the channel airs now
when they want to pay each other let's
say the second node wants to pay the
first
node so a they change the balances
then the first node wants to pay the
second one
and it goes on until suddenly
there is no more a bitcoin on the first
node
side and if the first node wants to pay
again
they have to reopen the channel so we
are assuming that when the channel
is depleted the two nodes immediately
close
and reopen an identical channel
and for simplicity or for a notation
that we're going to use
this is going to be the cause of the
channel given lambda 1 lambda 2
and l1 and l2 okay questions about the
model
you say an identical channel is uh
immediately open it's
which means with the same parameters are
one and two
yes yes we're assuming that because
their needs didn't change
they want to open the same channel that
they opened before
thanks thank you so
this another question did you
consider stuff like lightning loop
or just refreshing the channel with on
chain payment
so we haven't we thought this model
is rich enough in the results uh
it could be very very interesting to
put this into a deeper study
but there is an issue into putting money
into the channel because we're going to
try and optimize the size of
it and then in many cases it's going to
make
sense just to close and reopen if we
know this
but we haven't studied this and i think
it's a very interesting subject to study
okay thanks
so let's continue but again feel free
so this is the model of the channels
and and now we want to talk about the
cost
of the channel so a one cost comes from
closing and reopening
the channel this happens on chain
and we're going to denote the cost by b
and when we're going to compare this to
actions on chain we're going to assume
that closing and reopening a channel is
going to cost
two trans two transactions
on chain so a single transaction is
going to cost
us behalf and
okay so that's one thing we want to keep
in mind when we're asking how much does
the channel cost
another thing to keep in mind is
opportunity loss we're going to lock
some money in the channel and this money
can't be used for anything else we can't
buy a car we can't buy
s p 500 we can't do anything with it
and this is something that we need to
remember again when talking about
opportunity lost
we're going to keep in mind the interest
rate
and we're going just to mark it by the
letter r
and finally so there is a trade-off
between these two things
if we put a higher deposit this means
that we're going to close and re-open
the channel rarely but there is more
money inside of the channel that we're
not doing something else with it
on the other side if we're going to put
a lower deposit we'll have to close and
reopen the channel
very often so we'll have to play around
with balancing these two things
okay so um to
sort of warm up and get used to it we
want to ask should we open the channel
and to do this we're going to prove uh
the following dilemma
and just to sort of get used to all the
lambdas b's
are and things like that and dilemma
claims that unchain
settlements for a transaction stream
with rate lambda
is going to cost this okay and this is
not a very difficult
lemma and we need to introduce the
random variable
x k which counts the time until the k
transaction comes about okay
so the expected cost is going to be so
behalf
is just going to be the transaction fee
for sending this transaction
and this thing here is going to be
is representing the fact that paying
five dollars today
or five dollars in a year it doesn't
cost the same
five dollars in a year are much cheaper
than five dollars right now
and the way we're going to look at that
is this
e to the minus r times the
times the time until we actually going
to pay
this behalf for the k transaction
okay and then just let's run the numbers
so first of all we have linearity of
expectation which is always fun
so we can take the expectation in now
it's a bit of abuse of notation but
actually waiting for the case
transaction is the same as waiting
for the first transaction k times
because everything is independent this
is a poisson process
so we can assume that in so that
we can assume that x k is just the sum
of k independent x ones
so uh we can write it like this and
again because everything is independent
we can take the k outside okay
now the last thing we need to do is to
use the
moment generating function of the
poisson random variable
that tells us this and then we're just
summing
a geometrical summation
yeah and and we get
the following um number here
which of course agrees with the lemma
okay
so
um this is the general spirit of things
so now we can approximate how much
things are going to cost
on chain and now when we're talking
about should we
open a channel the the question we want
to ask
is okay so how much does a channel cost
and then compare these two numbers
so um good
so uh the cost of a lightning channel uh
this is something
this is the following so uh one the
first part of the theorem has to do with
unidirectional channels in so in
uni-directional channels we're assuming
that only the first node wants to send
bitcoin to the second node
so you'll find the transaction rate of
the second node zero
and of course the second node is not
going to deposit anything into the
channel because there's no reason
for them to do it and this is going to
be the cost of the unidirectional
channel
in the more general case when we're
thinking about a bi-directional channel
this is going to be the cost it's not a
very pleasant equation
but sometimes math is not pleasant and
we just have to
live with it um so that's that
and from this we can already start
asking
several questions so i won't run
through the whole work we proved things
uh exactly showing which relations
should lambda b and
r a hold for a channel to be opened
we we can also show from this
calculations the ratio between
on-chain transactions and transactions
on the lighting network
and other things but from here i want to
jump to
something that's going to be relevant
for the second part of the talk
which is the optimal cost in all of
these equations we're assuming that
the users put some l1 and l2
as a deposit but a very natural thing to
say is that they can think about it
and try to choose some l1 and l2 that
minimizes the cost
so now i want to talk about optimal
channels
and here we're going to talk asymptotics
and we're going to assume that the
interest rate
is going to zero which is a very common
assumption
so given this doing asymptotics
around when r goes to zero the minimal
cost of a
unidirectional channel is going to be
what you see
here and the optimal deposit
is what you see here similarly for a
symmetric bidirectional channel that is
when both sides
want to transact at the same rate lambda
the optimal cost is going to be what you
see here
and this is going to be the optimal
deposit
so the one thing i wanted to take from
this slide
is this difference okay so
as you see there is a difference in
order of magnitude
between unidirectional and symmetric
bi-directional channels
we can also use these results to give
bounds on asymmetric channels
i'll talk about this more in the open
question a
part but we don't have full optimality
results
for any asymmetric channels
and we think it's going to be very
interesting but already from the bounds
that we can get
from this we can say quite a few
interesting things
okay can you can you maybe so i have a
question
er so i'm trying to get a sense of the
directions of uh
growth so as the interest rate goes to
zero kind of my opportunity cost
to lock up money uh kind of decreases
because
i there's no point for me to invest it
anywhere because
yeah i will not get any any i mean i
could spend it but it's a different
story
so so as i do that it should get
kind of less it should get more and more
of a no-brainer to open a channel
because
i have this disposable income that i i
cannot invest because it's not useful
for me to do so so
how is it reflected here so i haven't
showed
the criteria for when do we want to open
a channel
but most like in the heart of it
is for a unidirectional channel is that
lambda needs to be greater than b over
r so when um
so for example here you see when r goes
to zero we are going to open
bigger channels for example and things
like that but
it doesn't appear here but it is
reflected
in the inequalities that have to do with
when do you want to open a channel and
when not
okay and here there's just some
different effect that is about lambda
versus bnr
here's the different effect is between
unidirectional and bi-directional
channel
so intuitively speaking in a
bi-directional channel you have
um things cancelling out so alice sends
one bitcoin to bob then bob
sends one bitcoin to her and we're back
at the starting position
so and one way to think about it is a
unidirectional channel
is just a random walk starting from
somewhere and then hopping hopping
hopping
until it hits a wall in the symmetric
bi-direction channel there are two walls
we're starting in the beginning and
we're sort of jumping back and forth
back and forth
at some point we're going to hit a wall
but it's going to take much longer
and from this the channel cost the
channel is going to
is going to be much cheaper because for
the same amount of
money inside of the channel the channel
stays open
longer and we don't need to pay fees as
often
right thanks yeah that helps anything
else
um maybe maybe i'll jump here uh
jump in here uh i mean you you probably
know about
all of these like multi multiple
channels with one pier you could just
add a second
channel that adds balance to your
connection with the
same peer and basically have
a rebalancing function that way
did you did you look into any sort of
rebalancing because
i i can think of like multiple ways that
are starting to get established
so we haven't because we wanted to keep
the model as cooling as possible
but i'm actually currently thinking
about rebalancing and using again the
formulas that you see here or the first
formula which was a bit more complicated
you can actually show how much can you
save with a rebalancing channel what are
the meaning of it and also a rebalancing
channel
something that it allows you is to
change the b
here because you can wait longer in our
model once the channel
closes you need to immediately reopen
one but if you
can do a transaction and wait for 24
hours until it goes into the network
you can save a lot of money there so
there's a bucket low
load of interesting questions that i'm
more than happy
to talk about um i'm seeing you next
week but
anybody else who's seeing this video
i'll have my email at the end okay
so thanks for your questions and to
continue asking them
so we talked about the optimal channel
sizes and as i said there's a
great difference between unidirectional
channels and
bidirectional channels and with this
we want to talk about the meaning of
these differences for the structure of
the lighting network
so i will have to take a moment and give
a few more
some definitions for the network so
we're going to have the nodes in the
networks which are going to be
v1 to vn and there's going to be an
underlying payment flow
so vi wants to pay vj with the rate
lambda ij this is just i don't know v i
buys coffee from vj
daily or something like that and
we're going to represent the lightning
network as a graph say
g with the same notes and the channel is
going to be a directed weighted edge
between between nodes that decided to
open the channel
and we're going to assume that all of
the lambda j's
ijs are either zero or large enough
for a for the transaction to happen
on the lightning network okay so these
are
just a small thing so we didn't get to
that part
but in the heart of it if you're not
transacting a lot if you're
a turtle to say you're not going to go
on the lighting network because it's not
going to be worth your while and you're
going to transact
on chain so this is an assumption we
have with us
so now we want to connect this landing
network
g to the underlying set flow of payments
f so we're going to say that the
weighted direct
graph g is a valid lightning network
with respect
to f if first of all for any pair v ivj
that want to transact
there is a directed path from vi to vj
they are able to do this
and say when everybody chose the paths
they are going to use for the payments
the weight of the edges
is going to be the sum of all of the
rates that are going to pass
through them okay intuitively speaking
the landing network is going to be a
graph
with a that's going to allow all
necessary payments
and the weights of the edges or the
sizes of the channels are going to be
optimized
to the payments that are expected to
flow
through them and we're going to denote
by f of g the cost of the lighting
network
and that's just going to be the sum over
all of the channels
so if we're feeling good with all these
definitions
we can start and ask ourselves how do we
expect the lighting network
to evolve in light of the costs of the
channels
so the one thing to remember about the
lighting network
it's decentralized nobody is going to
come from above and tell who should open
a channel with whom
people are going to open channels with
each other at their own discretion
making their own decision decisions but
if there is some money to be saved
we can assume that a small number of
users can decide to change
the channels between them if it's going
to benefit all of them
or at least not to harm the interests
of anybody there in our work
we're considering two possible changes
the first we call mutation so we're
assuming
there are four vertices for example
but in general there's a small group of
vertices i'm sorry
with channels between them and then they
can talk to each other
think about this and say okay we should
close all the channels we have
and reopen this new structure here
because it benefits
everybody another change that we're
assuming that may
that could happen we're calling
hermitization
and this is again we have say four
vertices
doing their thing and then a fifth
vertex
come in and says okay guys if you're if
everybody is going to transact through
me
you're going to save a lot of money so
as a business plan
v5 is going to take half and the other
savings
is going to go between all of them okay
so it's not going
not only is this going to be a not
expensive you're actually going to save
money and all of us are going to be
happy
okay so these are the main two changes
that we're going to allow inside of the
lightning network
okay so with this
changes we already can say
we can already show that there are
things that where
we do not expect to see in the lightning
network
so a theorem that a
we show is that oh sorry three immutable
means
three vertices agree four immutables
four vertices agree etc
so in the lighting network if every
three users can
talk with each other and get to some
agreement we will not see
cycles of length three where all of the
channels are bidirectional
and similarly if every four users can
talk to each other
and make decisions that benefit
everybody
we will not see cycles of length four so
for example let's assume uh these three
channels were open
and they're transacting with each other
at some point
somebody will realize that actually this
is a better structure
so a the a better solution would be
to give up the lower channel here and do
all of the transactions between the two
lower nodes
through this node up here okay
and a similar solution can be found
for c4 so uh
one reason that this result is
interesting
is that when we come when we decide to
simulate the lightning network for
various reasons
um often we use standard
models such as a small world or
preferential attachment
and in all these models where there's
going to be a lot of short cycles just
because of the structure
and from this perspective these models
and others are irrelevant or should be
used cautionary used with caution
when modeling the lightning network
so this is something that we won't see
another small structure
that we with that we're expecting not to
see is the following
it's a path of two is a directed path
of length two again let's assume that
these nodes for some reason decided to
create these two channels
at some point if the lambdas are large
enough
somebody is bound to notice that
actually
by asking the first node to pay
the third to use payments through the
third node
this makes the second channel
bi-directional
and bi-directional channels in general
are
much cheaper than unidirectional
channels so the first node just doesn't
care
because it's all the same and these two
nodes
are happy because this saves the costs
of the second channel here so um
oh and actually i like this result
because
in some sense this brings to light the
idea
of negative transaction fee so actually
this node here can if
this was an option should have offered a
negative transaction
fee to the first here for to the first
node here
because by transacting through the third
node
they will be saving money for the third
and the second node
and this result also tells us that the
graph spanned by unidirectional channels
is just going to be a union of
bi-directional channels
and there's a lot of limits that we can
again
show that all the uni-directional
graph and the bi-directional channels
that a graph channel that we can have
also has a lot of limits in the spirit
and yeah so
questions about this or the previous
slide
okay good so for now we talked about
local structure we said there is no
small graph
cycles of length four this direct a
directed path
but looking at this again there's also a
global
implication coming from these small
changes that users
are doing so a to introduce
this theorem i need to introduce a few
more definitions
so the degree of a node is just going to
be the channels adjacent to it
and we're going to mark by smallest and
large s
the smallest and largest weight of edges
adjacent to this vertex v and
what's actually going to be interesting
for us is this r of t
which is going to be the maximum of this
ratio
over all of the vertices in the network
so given that we can show the following
theorem
that a lightning network g that has an
average degree
greater than this is not hermetic
that is in somewhere inside of the
sliding network
there is a bunch of vertices that
somebody can step
in and tell them close all the channels
between you
create and do all of your transactions
through me
and it's going to be worth your while
you're going to save money
if you'll do that so just to be
a bit get comfortable with this maybe
weird
figure over here for example if all of
the weights are the same
that is r of g is one this means that
the average degree
has to be smaller than 5.66
which is not fantastic if we're thinking
about a network
and we were trying so this is a
i think the least scientific part of our
work we're just trying to guess
what this ratio rfg could be so we
opened our
visa printouts we started comparing like
where do we spend the most where do we
spend the least
i think the maximum we found is a at
a ratio of five we said okay what
happens if we put
in 10 and it's still not great this
still tells us that the lighting network
has an
average degree degree at most 12.7
if we we wanted not to have this
business opportunity for somebody
stepping
in and convincing nodes to transact
through them
and so this limit
on the on the average degree gives raise
to a
possible business plan we look at the
lightning network if we suspect the
average degree
is er to is too large
we just find a sub graph of vertices
that have a high minimal degree
the if the average is high this means
there is a sub
graph where all of the vertices have a
high degree
we offer all these vertices or nodes to
channel through us they save money we
get
fees and everybody is happy
the issue with that is that in general
law average degree
can be a threat to security to privacy
and to the stability of the network but
it doesn't have to be and i'll talk
about this a bit more
in the discussion so before we go into
the discussion any question about this
limiting the degree is theorem
okay good eh so let's have a quick
discussion
so we talked about the cost of a single
channel this is a basic step to
understand the lightning network
it gives raise to very interesting
questions such as
could the lightning network at some
point
leave the bitcoin behind because it's
not interesting in the same way the
dollar
left the gold and
so that's about the cost of a single
channel a limiting sub
graphs in the lighting network with
limited cycles of like three and four
paths of length two there are other
limits that we have
and so this gives us a reason to believe
that standard simulation tools
are not relevant for the lightning
network at least in the future
and we should think about different ways
to simulate the network
and we need to difference understand
structural implications
by no means have we found all of the
structures that we expect not to see so
there is
a lot more to study there furthermore
the low average degree and the reason we
should worry about this
is that currently there is no incentive
towards
expander expander-like structure so a
low degree
doesn't have to be bad okay we can have
very robust and
unstable graphs but we need them to be
expanders or something similar and
for now there is absolutely no incentive
that pushes the lightning network
in that direction and there is a lot of
incentive
to create a star-like structure or
something which is
very centralized and this is important
to think about
so here are some open problems
asymmetric channels
either discovering what are the optimal
what are the costs of the optimal
channels or at least
giving some good bounds to deeper
understand the network
and there's some a lot of game
theoretical questions
we were looking specifically at the
objective of
saving costs in a very specific model
we can think about alternative
objectives alternative models
and again how do we steer them
towards an equilibrium that we feel
comfortable with and we're thinking
is going to be healthy for the network
and
another open problem that we haven't
touched at all in our work
is the questions of fees what are going
to be the fees in the
the equilibrium and how are they going
to affect
the structure and in general the health
of the network
and so thank you for your time questions
comments
maybe you answered something while i was
chatting
thank you clara so other questions
so i do have a couple in maybe while
others are maybe processing
um so
how how much of uh sort of this theory
do we see reflected in the actual like a
network graph so for example structures
that shouldn't arise do they indeed
not arise or are they rare or are are
there like you know special features of
the graph that you know
maybe is worth trying to explain it's a
very good question but the lightning
network is very young
for example for now you can only open
um unidirectional channels at least in
spirit so you can transact both ways
but only alice can deposit something
into the channel
and bulb can't when they open so they're
planning to change this they're working
on the solution
um and another thing
for now the lighting network is mostly
hobbyists
people are doing it have for fun some
people are doing it professionally
looking into the future but there isn't
a lot of economic perspective in there
so the mbas
are not at the lighting network yet so
it doesn't look like anything
um that we expect
but this is not surprising because we're
trying to think about the lighting
network in the future when it would be
used at least on a daily basis so
for now uh lightning network looks i
think pretty much a preferential
attachment
um but if it's going to be a highly
like if it's going to be adopted there's
no way it's going to be stay
stay that way okay
thank you see there's a question go
ahead
yeah um i was wondering have you
compared how
the simulation based on your model
um looks uh in comparison to the
excellent lightning network that has
established itself
so we haven't and we haven't even so
we have a few do's and don'ts for
simulating
simulating the lightning network of the
future
of how do we expect it to be and but we
haven't done this
and in some sense i think
it's not going to be very useful because
the lighting network
now is not the way it's going to look
when it's going to be adopted
and used by you know general public
if you may
i i'd have more questions but if other
people have questions i'd
uh let them go first
yeah yeah go ahead i mean and also if
somebody else has a question they can uh
raise their hand yeah okay
yeah jacob um
yeah i raised my hand sorry um
like uh two kind of related questions
one is that it seems like the model is
more general than just lightning
um i was thinking throughout the talk of
like just banks doing settlement with
each other
not just and assuming there was some
similar cost structure some kind of
collateral they need to hold with each
other to lock down funds
like your models may be interesting for
like
the current finance world not just like
i think network and the questions that
people have been asked that has been
asking like
you can ask about that is the one bank
that
serves i know all of africa is you
predict that
it's going to be more efficient than a
bunch of small banks
so this is a very good question it has
to do with the
uh papers that we in the classical bomba
topping and
middle of all papers that we were
looking at
when we started this work a big
difference that you'll find between the
banking system and the lightning network
is that for example in the lightning
network you always have the option of
transacting on chain
the banking system is not a second layer
above something
unless you assume you're going to fly
around with the
dollars in uh in suitcases or something
like that
so i think that the comment is very good
in the sense that
i think it's this work is relevant for
other secondary solutions in other
cryptocurrencies
or come maybe
other solutions but it's not clearly
good for banks because they're
it's the first layer and not the second
um you're
even if you don't have the first there
you'll still have the cost
structure i think you your formulas for
the cost structures can still apply
um and the second question is like the
formulas
they gave like seem to rely um on the
on the random walk structure on the
randomness on the exponential rivals or
plus on arrivals
and of course it's it's a fine
assumption i was just
wondering whether you thought about
those expression given other
distributions
and whether we should think of like um
of um of like what would happen
if you had like more bulky transactions
let's suppose my uh transaction um
so something with that so in the model
the way i presented it we're assuming
that at any point
a others is sending exactly one bitcoin
which but so something we are already
proven that
this is more general than that so
we can show that pretty much the same
works
if we have some kind of a random
distribution
with some limits on it but hey we look
at that if the expectation
is lambda then it's going to look pretty
much the same
so this this is something that we looked
at
but we haven't looked at things like
dependencies or
other maybe more sophisticated models
um and always happy to talk about these
things because i think
this this is a very this is like a
basic building block but i think there's
a lot more to do
on top of this
right
was there one more question or yeah
i had more of a comment still and
there's a few
enterprises that are running
professional channels already like
bitfinex
and lightning labs of course and i was
just wondering whether you had
asked them what sort of
things they optimized their channel
operation for it might be informative
for
for building a more comprehensive model
so i had uh informal discussions with
them
um so i don't want to to speak for them
just
not to say something which is not exact
but i like for now there isn't
for specifically at least at the user
and there isn't really a deep
thought in that direction i think it has
a lot to do with the
engineering and technical challenges
that are currently focused at
they're thinking about this but i don't
think there was um
serious work done in that direction
and i'll be happy to learn uh
if there is
okay so maybe this is a good time for uh
taking a break break thank you thanks
again clara for
for the great talk so much
there's my email twitter um
i'm happy to hear any of your thoughts
so we'll resume with uh elaine's talk
let's say in
10 minutes so maybe um minutes past the
hour
and of course you know those of you want
to just stick around here and chit chat
and you're welcome to use them
a few